the reviews are in for The Last of Us on
HBO and things are looking bright for
this Bleak show on Gamespot sister site
Metacritic that shows current rating is
an 84 with 23 reviews gamespot's Mark
Delaney gave the first season a 9 out of
10 stating that quote The Last of Us
feels like a vital expansion of a
fictional Universe I love so much there
are things that only the video game can
do like put players in the boots of Joel
but there are things also unique to
television and The Last of Us shines
brightest when it recognizes and leans
into these opportunities make no mistake
The Last of Us on HBO feels like the
beginning of a new era for Live Action
video game adaptations I myself have
watched the first episode of the show
and mirror Mark's feelings exactly it's
incredibly faithful to the original game
but replaces the time taken up by
gameplay by adding meaningful and true
to the experience wrinkles to the
characters and story I think fans of the
game are going to be really happy while
great reviews of The Last of Us on HBO
are a pleasant surprise a somewhat
unpleasant surprise is that Xbox has
finally announced what is coming and
going from its Game Pass service this
January and the answers are
underwhelming on the one hand the
releases for the subscription are
excellent including Persona 3 Portable
Persona 4 Golden and Monster Hunter rise
on the other hand not only are those
simply ports of games that have already
come to other consoles albeit a much
easier option to play the two Persona
games but we already knew that these
games were coming to the service this
month what's perhaps more interesting is
what is leaving while none of the games
saying goodbye to Game Pass are massive
must play titles one of them is curious
as it's developed by an Xbox game Studio
we happy few from compulsion games
released in 2018 which was the same year
that the developer was purchased by
Microsoft however the game already had a
publishing agreement with gearbox which
may be why it's leaving Game Pass nearly
five years later Xbox would likely need
to keep paying gearbox to have it on the
service and Game Pass numbers are likely
showing that that wouldn't be worth it
head to gamespot.com for the full list
of games leaving game pass this month
all in all it's been a little bit of a
messy start of the year for Xbox which
is the last thing players wanted after
the last couple of messy years for Xbox
series X after not having anything to
display at the game awards in December
the console is rumored to be getting a
showcase at the end of the month to
highlight some of the year's releases
however that same rumor claims Xbox's
biggest game of 2023 Starfield won't be
present the platform has for many years
mostly been riding off of the success
and admiration Gamers have for the game
pass subscription something that Xbox
cannot afford to lose while there's
still so many excellent things to play
there it's something that needs to
continue building steam rather than
losing it and this January announcement
doesn't bode well for the former if
there's nothing for you on Game Pass at
the moment maybe you'd like to pick up
some discounted Nintendo games if you
haven't picked up Pokemon Scarlet or
Violet yet both games can be purchased
with almost 10 off each another great
Nintendo game from 2022 was Mario plus
Rabbids Sparks of Hope which is 20 off
and one from 2021 Metroid dread has a 15
savings Link in the description for the
full list of deals are you excited for
The Last of Us on HBO are you going to
be playing either of the Persona games
or maybe even Monster Hunter rise on
Xbox game pass this month let us know in
the comments and we'll see you here for
more Gamespot news
foreign